euromaxx I lights and here's your host
and O'Donnell thanks attorney is for
euromax highlights well let's have a
look at some of this week's festive fun
first up bright ideas and austrian
company lights of Europe at Christmas
place your bet people in Britain vote
for their favorite Christmas adverts and
in the money some lucky winners of last
year's Christmas lottery in Spain well
city centers and shopping malls around
Europe have been kitted out in their
annual Christmas attire baubles angel
hair and lights as far as the eye can
see much of that luminosity actually
comes from Austria that our gist
European supplier of Christmas lights
can be found in the city of innsbrook
and they have as many different kinds of
orders as there are countries
glittering lights are an essential part
of the Christmas celebrations sculptures
that the great cities across Europe
during the holiday season they're all
the work of one designer gear kula a
master of Christmas illumination record
it is from my overall concept is that I
want to evoke emotions and transport
people back to their childhood to call
up those powerful memories we have of
our first Christmas or the first one we
can remember I grew up in tirol and I
remember walking into the living room
and being surprised by the illuminated
Christmas tree Atkins you go Austin in a
honking Turkish pomnish be life after
drafting his designs fula consults with
the rest of the team at MK illumination
the company has its headquarters in in
spoke Austria and has branches in 28
countries around the world it's Europe's
largest supplier for Christmas
illuminations and sells its
installations in 120 countries
soshanguve all we always look to see if
there are interesting local things we
can incorporate that's more exciting
than having everything look the same
everywhere and when people see we're not
just copying and importing designs from
somewhere else we have a stronger
connection to what we've created the
devil's bidding which on those came off
function on business trips mark sits at
the window so that he can draw
inspiration from the ocean of lights
down below he and his team draw on local
themes and culture in their designs here
in South Africa the result was a rhino
in lights in Sweden it was reindeers
every country has its own preferences
Scandinavians tend to prefer traditional
designs they need not too much color
someone restrained Nordic and refined
notation over but in southern Europe
Christmas illuminations are quite
different like here in the Italian city
of salerno
you
crazy colors crazy colors all the colors
of the rainbow the busier it is the more
action the better mindles minds of you
get the sense that your eyes are moving
constantly from one thing to the next
well it's clearly out and coming on it
to who it sometimes the illuminated
sculptures become a local landmark
during the festive season like this one
in central Stockholm it took more than a
year to come up with a design iron you
feat wonky when you create animal
sculptures you also pay attention to the
facial expression which helps create the
sense of identification from design we
are blessed with a fantastic team of
designers one of the strengths of MK
illumination is the sculptural element
the way we take an idea in the sketch
and translate it into a 3d sculpture
another is the craftsmanship every piece
is welded together by hand and that's
what lets us create sculptures that
evoke an emotional response these are US
team Erica keeps on a simple certain
sympathy plague on switch off every year
before Christmas about 1,000 light
installations takes shape across Europe
over a three-week period it's a
logistical challenge and business is
booming in order to compete with online
retailers store owners try to create a
memorable shopping experience
illumination plays an important role
Saint cough Lutsen elated turn shopping
into an experience retailers that do a
better job creating a setting that
customers and joy are more successful
what really pleases me is the way light
can please people it's magical it makes
people happy makes children smile
children are important because they
decide where you go to shop it's the
children who say let's go and look at
the elk again mama get my instant LF it
on Sean
during the weeks before Christmas
designer Gila likes to visit cities that
are decked out in his designs he wants
to see how people react to his work
it's great that makes me happy it's
pretty when it shines you starin Andy
listen you can wish on the Stars and
then make your wishes come true here it
helps people spend an extra euro or two
it makes you wanna shop and it gets you
in the Christmas spirit Christmas
illuminations are a winner when it comes
to creating a festive mood and for
retailers that means attracting lots of
customers on it in full festive swing
here today for the euro max highlights
show and one of the key ingredients for
any Christmas of course is the tree we
take a look at the history of the famous
firs that light up many living room
around the globe
in Germany know Christmas is complete
without a Christmas tree but where
exactly did the tradition originated the
Vioxx house in whose of northern Germany
is a museum devoted to the topic of
Christmas it's run by Alex Paulson
my controls are you could say Christmas
is a very German holiday the first time
a fir tree was decorated with lights was
in a german-speaking region exactly
where is still a matter of debate we'll
never know for sure but there was an
early version of a christmas tree in
Silesia engadin the Germans tree of
choice is the Nordmann fir grown in some
7,000 Christmas tree plantations across
the country and cut down when they're
eight to 12 years old the tree
originally comes from the Caucasus
Mountains it's popular because it tends
to be straight its needles are
relatively soft and it doesn't shed too
much but it's less fragrant than the
other trees even so around 75 percent of
German Christmas trees are Nordmann firs
Matthias bhajan decorates Christmas
trees for companies in hotels
in Bullock is man ass punk rock it's
supposed to symbolize the birth of Jesus
you new life in the world Richie many
people would hang a tree somewhere in
the home to represent a paradise tree or
a tree of life hadith ball Molina
thought the Christmas tree used to be
considered a pagan tradition only in the
mid 19th century did the custom become
widespread ironically this peaceful
tradition began in wartime in Dodge
francis's during the franco-prussian war
of 1870 271 the Kaiser had small
decorated trees placed in hospitals and
camp sees the soldiers who survived the
war then introduced this as a custom
once they return home there have been
Christmas trees and homes ever since Nam
is to bear in mind outside static afoot
in the beginning people would decorate
their trees not with ornaments but with
fruit and nuts but legend has it that
there came a time in the mid 19th
century when glass blowers and Lucia
thuringia could no longer afford these
treats so they started making glass
ornaments instead
glass blown Christmas ornaments are
still made the old-fashioned way in Lao
Zhang the glass surface gets a coating
of silver to make them shiny auras hand
painted this moon face was made with a
mold dating from 1910 a hundred years
ago Christmas decorations were
incredibly diverse and filigree that the
tide life doomed the craftsmen who made
these forms were meticulous and
professional they don't make Christmas
ornaments like that anymore commitment
with the dog in here and that's a pity
but it makes the old pieces even more
valuable Soviet fullest in Dundee I
didn't something
back in Berlin florist Matthias botanist
hard at work over 23 million Christmas
trees are sold in Germany each year most
people favor classic decorations many
traditional trimmings are symbolic
Christmas ornaments are actually
supposed to evoke the Apple in the story
of Adam and Eve tinsel is thought to
represent angel hair of the star at the
top of the tree is of course a reference
to the Star of Bethlehem how long I did
there are always some new trends with
Christmas trees like replacing them with
a single abstract branch any minimalist
ornaments but in recent years families
and older generations have come to
appreciate the romance of an
old-fashioned tree they remind us of our
childhood and it would be a shame if we
stop trimming them they're lovely and
symbolic would it it takes three hours
to get the tree sparkling time now from
a TS button to start wrapping some gifts
Christmas presents were originally small
enough to hang on the tree but as they
got bigger they ended up under it moving
on to the UK now where nothing is safe
from the bookmakers especially at
Christmas time when the breath seemed
keen to back anything in sight they put
money on everything from the weather
who's going to sing the Christmas number
one they even place bets on who will
produce the best Christmas TV ad huge
department stores Bartlett age every
year to see who can create the top
Christmas commercial so who's it going
to be this year that's going to have the
king of a Christmas advertising title
let's have a look they are elaborately
produced and hotly anticipated and every
year when they launched in late November
but Christmas advertising campaigns of
Britain's major department stores
captivate the nation I can feel the
warning sign within days the TV spots go
viral
then the race is on for the year's best
Christmas commercial and companies go to
great lengths and expense to come out on
top through brand loyalty and through
their advertisement they tried to key to
create an emotional bond with with the
consumer in 2007 when I think John Lewis
started creating these advertisements
and then they setting the bar pretty
high and every year they try to set the
bar even higher and making adverts
better and more connected and
emotionally connected a favorite this
year is the two-minute spot man on the
moon before the department store chain
John Lewis innate a young girl discovers
a lonely man in the moon the underlying
messages many elderly people have to
spend Christmas all by themselves a
commercial cost a reported 9.5 million
euros to make it became a runaway
youtube sensation clocking more than 22
million clicks to date that is eclipsed
by sainsbury's commercial which features
mog the calamity prone cat who
accidentally sets his family's house on
fire and nearly ruins of Christmas mog
is a much-loved children's book
character that has enjoyed celebrity
status in Britain for decades mogs one
of the nation's best-loved literary
characters I've got two young children
and I remember reading mode to them as
part of that bedtime routine the idea is
very much like last year about Christmas
is for sharing we wanted to do something
that really brought families together at
Christmas and we think mark is a perfect
character to do that
a battle for best Christmas ad is the
subject of heated debate every year Oh
what would you say I'd say the same
screen swan the same three I'm gonna go
to the John Lewis one he's more
emotional in there John never said mate
was more emotional yeah it's a good
advert I think just makes cry one factor
fueling this unofficial competition is a
national love of betting on anything and
everything Britain is a nation founded
on uncompetitive ideals it's the country
where that gave birth to two a lot of
the sports and the games that we play
around the world so there's betting in
every aspect of life it's not just
betting on a horse's butt people in
Britain do tend to bet on all sorts of
absurd things department stores are
naturally also vying for the spending
not just the hearts of viewers the
telescope featured in the John Lewis
cliff sold out online within minutes of
the ads to view but the biggest game to
be made is a boost in company image that
is why the campaign's include charities
and encourage viewers to donate
actually that commercial activity can
also lead to people giving money to good
causes and Britain does have a really
strong tradition of charity this year
Sainsbury's campaign has another trump
card it features a cameo appearance by
the famous children's book author Judith
Kerr who invented mog the cat in the
1970s I never really thought I'd see
Morgan 3d the original mug i think
nevel's never thought that would happen
to her touching characters at a
charitable message wrapped up in
emotional packaging it's a recipe that
has only recently struck a chord in
British hearts these have really quite
emotionally incontinent little little
movies which are widget which are meant
to bring tyr tyr to the eye and I think
they they sort of they show you that I
think yeah a country which used to be so
famously emotionally repressed is is no
more it's actually been a very happy
about the idea of crying in public
and naturally every Christmas story
needs a happy end the neighbors help
rebuild the house
the old man feels less alone and
ultimately every film that softens a
stiff upper lip can be classified a
winner
well in Spain the festive season would
not be complete without the annual
Christmas lottery people often get
together to buy tickets in the hope of
hitting the jackpot we caught up with
one group of museum workers who won big
in the annual draw each December Spain
holds its Christmas lottery often the
staff of entire companies take part as
seen in a current TV ad featuring
workers in a mannequin Factory it's the
world's largest prize drawing in 2014
the Madrid wax museum landed el gordo
the big one the jackpot of 64 million
euros the museum spokesman Gonzalo presa
remembers the moment very well full
momento Guerrera medium so here was a
moment when dreams become reality way
over here you just can't imagine that
happening and then someone says hey
that's the number that the museum bottle
both ed must give it I mean think then I
confirmed it really wasn't mad as the
museum spokesman the first thing I did
was send a press release to all the
media saying a team Madrid wax museum
had been blessed with a jackpot from the
Christmas lottery I said about the other
one more than I celebrated only
afterward places not least I have to do
my job a trabajo the museum's 32 staff
members had been playing the lottery
together for years friends relatives and
co-workers often share the expensive
tickets the museum staff had bought 160
tickets at 20 euros each the winning
sheer came to four hundred thousand
euros per ticket
I'm flood the Viacom open on Castle with
my lottery winnings I bought a house and
paid off all my outstanding bills and
bank oh yeah I now I can just enjoy life
the offal goal and without all that
worrying I work with a lot more energy
heating up but akeboshi an ass at the
museum itself little seems to have
changed
the AMA scale of about eighty percent of
the staff still work here they're
happier much but they don't think
working at something you enjoy is also a
kind of jan 5 i'll get the host i'm not
though not everyone has that that's good
luck in itself i count myself lucky so
I'm staying here Spain's Christmas
lottery dates back over 200 years it
distributes over two billion euros in
several thousand prizes the numbers and
payouts are drawn from separate raffle
drums the draw is broadcast live on TV
and goes on for hours to pupils from the
Samuel Afonso school draw the 1774
numbers and sing them out loud last
year's jackpot number was 134 37 the
numbers that the betting pool that the
wax museum had played the multi-million
euro jackpot made the museum and its
staff famous overnight
LCS famoso cristiano ronaldo is famous
in the true sense of the word because of
his own accomplishments but I'm not it's
simply good fortune about since december
twenty second last year i feel a lot
happier you'd is that a bit dizzy get a
mess maybe those studies showing lottery
winners are just as happy or unhappy six
months after their win as they were
before are wrong after all just before
christmas spain is overtaken by lottery
fever the ticket holders are hoping
they'll be as lucky as the museum staff
a tip from a past winner to a future
winner yep in yo yo guy got that a you
score a big payoff like 1 million euros
keep your feet as firmly on the ground
as Cristiano Ronaldo does on the soccer
pitch each day down to earth and enjoy
life and everyone knows life is a water
and the payout is to live normally and
stay healthy and if you should have the
kind of good fortune that we did so much
the better oh yeah but yeah
gonzalo presa has one final piece of
advice visit the madrid wax museum it's
the luckiest museum in the world or in
done work now Denmark lair where we
visited a truly stunning home it belongs
to a fashion designer makara Visnic who
has created numerous collections from
major labels so she obviously has an eye
for style and detail in fact her
beautifully decorated home is often
featured in design magazines on top of
that she lives in a fantastic listed
building in the heart of the Danish
capital in the Danish capital Copenhagen
everything is easily reached by bike the
listed building that Mikhail avsnitt
calls home is located in a quiet street
in the city centre
hello welcome to my home
the fashion designer shares the 190
square meter five room apartment with
her son it boasts original stuccoed
ceilings original doors and window
frames just as they were 100 years ago
when the house was built I was not
allowed to change anything else but to
repaint the walls and to pigment to the
floors that's a part of living in a
historical apartment where you actually
feel that there has been a history
before you came I love it I could never
met him to live in a new house even the
cupboards and tiles in the kitchen our
original features these are from the
when the house was built in 1915 and
they are very historical preserved for
me they're lovely because i really like
everything was with ornaments and once
they really inspired me for a piece of
clothes for prints on clothes and i
think they are gorgeous be snakes own
fashions reflect the focus on inspiring
details and creative mix of materials
that define her interior style she works
from home after 20 years with big-name
houses like christian lacroix she now
has her own label it's very important to
me to be in a personal environment where
i can always if I don't have an idea
here on my table I can turn around and
find a wonderful news ill adult green
color for the new collection I'm always
on an inspiration trip it could be
sunday night at eight o'clock I have an
idea so for me there is a very there's
no fine line between work and private
line
makara spends a lot of time traveling
both for business and pleasure souvenirs
from her travels can be found in her
apartment this piece is a special piece
because I found her in the flea market
in New York and of course we all my son
and me was not clear about how we should
take her home because she was quite
heavy so she traveled on in the hand
luggage with us so she was sitting next
to us in the air played this piece also
has a special story because it was in
Hanoi in Vietnam I was going by a little
shop with the tailor and we had a very
traditional little tailor Vietnamese
jacket with the traditional clothing and
it was quilted and I really loved it and
then I asked him to do a big blanket in
the same fabric and the same quilt nice
neck cleverly combines different styles
and periods
the danish modern classic pieces
especially like these couches and a lot
of other pieces is very well blending in
with the asian japanese furniture design
because it's a story about they actually
speak very well together it's less is
more there is nothing extra mokelumne
snacks apartment reflects her personal
aesthetic it's a serene sophisticated
space with personal memories from around
the world that's it thanks for watching
and from all the crew have a very happy
Christmas and we'll see you soon here
bye-bye
you